ah
[Music]
this podcast was recorded before the
recent events in the uk
where a policeman has murdered a woman
walking home completely innocent and
doing nothing wrong
took all the precautions and still this
thing
keeps happening and i just wanted to
start off with a little message of
respect
you know it's awful what's going on and
this is a trigger warning
um today's podcast is a conversation
with a survivor
of kidnapping and rape and
um yeah i just want to make you aware of
that before it starts
uh obviously i support
the campaign going on right now for
women to feel safer on the streets
um you know i know i'm a lads lad and i
make a lot of jokes and stuff like that
but
you know this is serious and yeah
i think a lot of men up there probably
reflected you know
should i say this should have said that
in the past you know because it just
makes you realize now what women have to
go through when you're saying it on such
a scale
where they just don't know who is
dangerous and who isn't dangerous so
they have to treat everyone
potentially like they could be and i
think maybe out there
men are feeling a little bit like well
it isn't me and
and but but you know we need to not feel
like take this personally we need to
realize that if we had daughters
and we were telling them they were going
out on a night out treat everyone like
they could be because you just never
know
and that's all they're trying to do so i
i get it
and i think you know a lot of things
have been going on in the past that
you know like people whistling out of
their cars and stuff like that was back
in the day that was just seen as the
norm but now
in the world we're living in things have
to change and you know it's important
women feel
safe so um yeah this podcast is one of
the
most emotional powerful podcasts i've
ever
done and one of the most important
because
i do want to use my platform for good
and as much as i love making people
laugh
um you know raising awareness to what
these victims go through
can can only be a good thing so
i hope you guys get as much from her
words as i did
it's elizabeth smart on the true jody
podcast
i was a pretty quiet kid i was pretty
shy
i think it'd be fair to say i was very
much a wallflower
i had a great childhood i had a great
family i had lived a very sheltered life
i lived a very protected life
none of us ever imagined anything bad
could happen to anyone in our
neighborhood
and i remember my parents getting us
ready to go to bed and
i actually even remember going around
with my dad checking the doors and the
windows in my house to see that they
were
closed and that they were locked and
then i remember going to bed
up until that point in my life the
things that scared me
were doing poorly on a test or going
to my music lessons unprepared and so
all of a sudden
hearing this voice this man's voice that
i didn't recognize
saying i have a knife at your neck don't
make a sound get up and come with me
i mean that just brought a whole new
meaning
to the word scared fourteen-year-old
elizabeth smart
was abducted from her home elizabeth
smart was taken from her bedroom in the
middle of the night every parent's worst
nightmare
now the kidnapping happened around two
o'clock this morning again as we said in
the salt lake federal heights area
i mean this was the biggest mad search
ever put on for anyone
we're doing everything we possibly can
to help you my older brother
i remember talking to him and he was
just like a day didn't go by
without your face being all over the
news newspapers or magazines he was like
it was
everywhere we begin today with the
statewide alert for the missing girl and
the man who took her
no one had been there to stop him from
doing anything
he wanted to me so when he would
threaten me and say
i will kill you if you don't do exactly
what i tell you to do
i believed him and that's when he said
that i
was now his wife and then he kept saying
over and over
it's now time to consummate our marriage
and i just remember thinking
why would someone
marry a child
[Music]
welcome back to the true geordie podcast
i don't usually do remote interviews but
uh i've decided to
make an exception today for a woman who
really is an inspirational person
after reading up on a and reached out
and luckily we've got the interview
um welcome elizabeth smart uh nice to
meet you
thank you it's sad that sometimes such
inspirational people have to
go through a lot of struggle uh to
to become that inspiration but your
story is something that
when i start researching it it just
really blew me away and not just
obviously um it was how you dealt with
that
that blew me away the strength that
you've shown in your life
is something where it's just
unbelievable
uh to be honest um you know just to fill
the audience
in um when you were 14 um you were
kidnapped
and um held for nine months
and um you went through a lot in that
time
and you've not let that define you
you've gone on to do so many amazing
things i really want to cover some of
those
today but um i guess i just wanted to
start off by
asking what you were like before
all of that and what you sort of had
planned for your life or
what kind of kid you were
i was a pretty quiet kid i was pretty
shy
i think it'd be fair to say i was very
much a wallflower
um i mean i was
not popular um i had friends but i
i was not the popular one by any means
and um i mean i was yeah i was excited
to be done with
junior high i was excited to go to high
school you know i came from a large
family i was second of
six kids so you know there's always a
bit of
a struggle when there's that many kids
as far as being heard and
um i don't know standing out from them
but
no it was i had a great childhood i had
a great family
i lived in a really nice neighborhood
none of us ever imagined anything bad
could happen to anyone in our
neighborhood
i mean i don't think any of us could
ever even imagine anything bad happening
to anyone i mean sure we watched the
news but that almost seemed like it was
a different world
because it was the news it wasn't you
know was anyone we knew
yeah the news doesn't feel real does it
until it's sort of
to your effect they buy something um
serious
um you know at 14 um when i was
at school there was 14 year olds who
were way too grown up and they were 14
year olds who were
you know like really childish i guess
someone drink mentally what kind
of kid you were at that age um i was i
don't think i was
childish i think i was naive
i think i was i mean i think i was very
polite i was very respectful i didn't
act like a
spoiled baby spoiled brat at 14.
but i was i lived a very sheltered life
i lived a very protected life
so i i mean i didn't really know
a whole lot about sex i mean i don't
learn what it was
you know a couple years earlier from my
friend across the street telling me
and when she told me that i about died i
remember just thinking that is
awful that's so bad i mean doesn't
anybody realize like that is where the p
comes out that is so nasty um
and that was still i mean that was still
my thoughts on what sex was i mean rape
i didn't even know
i didn't even really know what rape was
i didn't know
and certainly i didn't think there was a
difference between sex and rape and
i mean i did there was a lot of things
that i had been
very sheltered from that i didn't know
um
yeah your family were a beautiful family
from everything i've
i've seen they seem such good wholesome
people so
part of that naivety is them doing such
a great job
you know protecting you from things that
you shouldn't know at that age
yeah i mean both my parents were very
active very involved in
all of our lives and i mean we had very
clear boundaries set within our family
and
there were rules and um i mean i think
probably all of us
honestly felt like we had the most
strict parents of all of our friends
but um i mean i
like looking back and as a parent now
myself i'm like oh yeah
i get why they did that yeah it's like
that i suppose um
and and going back to the the day
of the that your life changed um
can you take me through what that sort
of if you can remember how the day went
up until that moment um just so
we can get an idea of what it was like i
remember
going to school talking with my friends
talking about our summer plans
i remember the cross country coach from
the local high school had come over to
my junior high and had said oh you
should try out for the team and i was
pretty excited about that because
i had never been particularly athletic
um and so i remember going home that day
and just pestering my mom to let me go
for a run
but i mean even before anything happened
she was like you can't go by yourself
you can't go by yourself you're a 14
year old girl you can't go by yourself
and
i mean we lived in a safe neighborhood
she's like take your sister with you and
take the dog with you
so i remember taking my sister taking
the dog going out for a run we got back
later than we anticipated
uh that night was like the awards
assembly for our school
and so i remember rushing to that with
my parents after dinner
remember getting home and i remember my
parents getting us ready to go to bed
and i actually even remember going
around with my dad
checking the doors and the windows in my
house to see that they were closed
and that they were locked and then i
remember my parents calling us together
for our evening family prayer and then i
remember going to bed
the doors and the windows were were they
locked were they all locked because i
so a lot of them were quite high off of
the ground
and there was a couple of windows in our
kitchen
that they were just skinny they were
more narrow windows
and i didn't check those but my dad he
checked them but he must have just left
them cracked open just a little bit my
mom
she actually had burnt dinner that night
which is
like unheard of for her and so there's a
little bit of that
burnt smell lingering and so i think he
must have just left one of the windows
cracked open just a little bit
to try to air the kitchen out but
everything was locked up but
i mean even locking the doors even
though we did that it wasn't something
that we were like
oh did you lock the doors did you double
check the doors did you triple check the
doors like
all the windows look because we we lived
in a nice neighborhood
yeah it was a beautiful place we thought
we lived in a very safe neighborhood i
mean
you know i grew up playing um night
games out in the middle of our street
with the neighbor kids
almost every night in the summer so it
wasn't something that we were
actively worried about something bad
happening
which makes it even more shopping really
like
for someone who's just had such a nice
upbringing in such a idyllic
place to then you you wake up
and you have a stranger in your bedroom
um what what was that like
it was terrifying it i up until that
point in my life
the things that scared me were doing
poorly on a test
or maybe when my parents had told me to
clean my room
20 times and then i could hear them
coming up the stairs and i still hadn't
done
anything that kind of scared me a little
bit or
going to my music lessons unprepared or
i mean probably the stupidest thing that
scared me
was the movie the never ending story
those were the kinds of things
that scared me and so all of a sudden
hearing
this voice this man's voice that i
didn't recognize saying
i have a knife at your neck don't make a
sound get up and come with me
i just i didn't even think it was real
at first i thought it had to be part of
my imagination part of my
subconscious partner even yeah yeah
but um the voice repeated those same
words again
i have a knife at your neck don't make a
sound get up and come with me
and i remember opening my eyes and it
was real
i mean there was a man standing above me
i could feel something cold
i could feel something sharp on my neck
i could feel someone's hand on my arm
trying to pull me out of bed
and i i mean that just brought a whole
new
meaning to the word scared
um yeah i think you've really painted
such a good picture in just how
you know um sheltered you were and then
to have the horrors of the world
wake you up one day like that it's it's
such a contrast to anything you've ever
known before i can only
um imagine what a shot that must have
been
with it being i'm assuming you slept in
the dark so i'm assuming
he could you see him like his face or
could you really make that out um i
couldn't really make out his face
too much i mean the room we slept in
it was night i mean obviously it was
dark but there was a street light
not too far away from my bedroom window
and i mean i i grew up in utah
we've got blue skies clear skies
probably
250 days of the year and uh so
i mean it was dark but it was light
enough that i could
make out some of his features not not as
well as
in the daytime but i mean i could see
darker shadows and
less shadows of his face and i could
tell he had a beard and
i could tell he had a like a a snow
stocking cap on and i could tell that he
was dressed in dark clothes and had a
bag
with him and one of the things that
makes this even more terrifying is that
your
sister was in the room with you as well
so you're also worried about her i
assume
yeah my sister and i we shared a room
forever i mean we had always shared a
room and
we actually at that point in time we
shared a bed
even and
so when i had woken up and he started
telling me to go with him
um i mean i was scared i was scared for
myself i had to wonder how he got all
the way up to my room because my room
wasn't on the ground floor
i mean my room was probably at the
highest point of the house you had to go
up a flight of stairs you had to wrap
around the house you had to go down a
hallway
you had to walk past my brother's
bedrooms
um i mean you you really had to
penetrate deep
into my home before you could get up to
my room and he had managed to do that
and so i didn't know had he already
killed
my family members i mean doesn't
everyone have that one
stare that one step in their house
that's extra squeaky
when you go up them i mean how have you
gone past that and my parents not heard
i mean they always seem to catch us
whenever we tried to sneak down to the
kitchen in the middle of the night or
i mean why why hadn't they come did
something happen to them
and i remember laying there and the one
thing i could tell was that she was
still
alive she was asleep i could hear her
breathing i could see her breathing
and so i felt like i didn't have a
choice i felt like i
had to get up and go with him and do
what he said
because if i didn't he might take her or
he might hurt her or he might kill her
yeah i mean a lot of people can sit
there and say what they would have done
in that situation but when you've uh
when you feel that cold blade against
you i can only imagine
how how terrifying that is so you know
luckily you didn't fight really in my
opinion anyway but
um do you look back at that situation
and have any
you know things that you would have done
differently or are you grateful that you
just
stayed alive in that moment knowing
everything that i know
now that you know most predators are
predators as long as there's
vulnerability as long as there's
opportunity
certainly i was asleep so of course i
was vulnerable but if i screamed you
know would that opportunity have
disappeared
would he have been too worried about
saving himself to get out of the house
or would he have killed me
it's hard to say and so when people ask
me do i regret
not doing something or would going back
would i do something else my answer is
no
i wouldn't change what i did because
i don't know what he would have done i
mean it would not have been that hard to
apply just a little bit more pressure
and slit my throat um
it wouldn't have been that hard for him
to just
stab me and wherever he wanted the face
the neck the stomach
my chest wherever and turn around and
run out of the house
so i don't regret doing what i did and
actually i think it's a
pretty important point to make because
there are
so many of us who who do freeze when
something like this happens and it's
actually a very
natural response i mean not everyone
fights back not everyone
is able to run away um the two probably
less talked about
sort of natural reactions are to freeze
or to appease and i feel like what
happened to me was a mixture of both
and ultimately i'm here today i survived
so i don't regret doing what i did and
nor should any other victim or survivor
second guess what they've done
because they're still alive and whatever
horrors they've experienced
at the end of the day it's not their
fault and this blame should not be put
on them for doing something more
very well said yeah we're i'm aware that
uh there are victim blamers out there
and i think it's
great that you touch on that because you
know it's
completely crazy for me for anyone to
blame a victim for what happens to them
you know and you know we're 14 years old
i can only imagine i think 99.9 of 14
year olds would have done the same thing
as you um so yeah i completely support
what you're saying there
um so this guy then tries to get you out
of the house
um how did that whole thing play out
because you're sort of hoping that
someone's gonna notice i'm assuming that
whole time
i mean i remember he actually walked me
into my closet
and he had me i started to reach for a
pair of
slippers to put on because they were
easy to put on but he specifically
pointed out and said no
take those shoes and they were my like
they were my running shoes
so i grabbed my running shoes instead
and
then he led me back out through my
bedroom
down the hallway around the corner down
the stairs
around the corner again in through the
kitchen and he went to the back door
unlock the door and i remember as we
approached the back door thinking
oh when he opens this door
the alarm's going to go off
but he opened the door and the alarm did
not go off
and um i guess the magnet that was set
in the frame
had fallen out or i don't know
it didn't go off though and i remember
he
at this point i still didn't even have
my shoes on i was still carrying them
and i grew up in a neighborhood that was
on uh one of the mountain sides that
overlooks the salt lake
city valley and so my backyard i mean
it's
it's steep it's mountain and i remember
he led me up through my backyard and it
wasn't fenced it
opened up into a vacant lot and then
we got to the top of my backyard close
to the
vacant lot he had me sit down put on my
tennis shoes
then he had me get back up and we kept
going we talked got to the top of this
vacant lot where
there's one more street in our
neighborhood and after this street
um it's just just mountains after that
and instead of crossing right away he
pushed me down behind some bushes
i remember just thinking what is going
on
and then i could see some headlights
coming towards us i started thinking oh
this is the getaway car
this is all planned no one is ever gonna
find me what is gonna happen i mean am i
gonna live to see another day
am i ever gonna see my family again what
is
what's gonna happen next and i remember
the
headlights getting closer and i actually
remember them passing right in front of
me
and i remember seeing the word police
written on the side of the car
and for that half a second that it was
in front of me i just remember thinking
it's gonna be okay
the police are here they're gonna come
rescue me everything's gonna be fine i
just
it's gonna be fine the police are here
but unfortunately they didn't stop they
kept going
and that's when he pulled me off the
ground had me run across the street and
start heading up into the mountains on
the other side
i'm assuming the possibilities
are really starting to run through your
head at that point of
okay what happens next then because now
he's got me
yeah i mean i remember asking him as we
got farther away from my home i kept
asking him
why was he doing this what was he to do
to me and he'd really kind of switch
between a couple answers
one of them was he said he was taking me
as his hostage
he was going to hold me for ransom
we got farther and farther up and i just
i just remember trying to
reason with them i mean my family never
hurt anyone as far as i knew nobody had
any grudges against
us why would he do this why did he
choose me
how did he get into her house and a lot
of the
a lot of my questions he just kind of
responded with
um he'd say something
like well i'll tell you when we get to
where we're going or
you'll find out in due time was his tone
of voice
um aggressive or was it calm or what
kind of
state of mind did he look like he was in
at that moment he was overall pretty
calm
but it was definitely i mean there was
definitely
a
seriousness to his voice i mean
it it wasn't like he it he didn't act
scared
he didn't act like this was something
he'd never done before
he didn't he acted like he had planned
out
everything like he knew where he was
going
um he knew exactly what to do he wasn't
gonna take
no for an argument he wasn't going to
allow me that he would um
for as calm as he was he made it very
clear to me that
i could not run from him and that
i could not fight him he still had his
knife
he still he was holding on to me for a
lot of the run
the run a lot of this i don't know his
escape plan
and it was i mean it was pretty
difficult there was a lot of trees there
was a lot of brush
if he ever let go of me i mean it was at
a point in time where it was so steep it
was almost like
we were going up this canyon it was just
so narrow and so steep and there are so
many trees
it just i couldn't have gotten far even
if i did try to run
when i was uh reading up on this from
what i remember
and you you could tell me if i'm wrong
he mentioned something about god
during this whole thing is that right
yeah he did
he did uh i mean when the police car
passed in front of us and he was holding
me down behind the bush
i remember him saying he said you know
if this work is true god let this car
pass
and i remember hearing that just
what what
i guess that gives a window into the
kind of state of
crazy state of mind this guy's in like
if he's thinking that
taking a 14 year old girl from her home
and holding her knife point is the god's
work
like this is clearly a man who's
completely out of his mind
it's just crazy that so um he's
he's planned his escape route out and
he's dragging you
all this way do you know how far you got
before
you settle yes i actually do
it was so where the hideout was
to my house it was 3.3 miles
um that's quite shocking for people i
would imagine because obviously
it's so close to your house but then as
you were saying
there's so much um land that's um that
terrain that people wouldn't
travel across it's highly unlikely that
they would have found him i guess well
and i think when most people
um hike or explore
they tend to stay either on the top of
the mountains
or they stay at the base of them and
where this hideout was located i mean we
went all the way we went
far far up this um canyon and then we
crossed over the top of the mountain
but we didn't go to the bottom and we
didn't stay at the top we kind of stayed
in the
upper middle third of the mountain so
and there was nothing that really stood
out about where i was held captive i
mean it pretty much
looked the same as the rest of the
mountains so there would be no reason
for someone to
have their attention drawn to this
location there'd be no reason for
someone to pay extra special attention
to it or anything i mean it
it just looked like the rest of the
mountain
and the real strange thing for me
hearing about it was that there was a
woman
waiting there which you know
as a as a young girl you're thinking oh
there's a woman maybe she can you know
help me
i mean i remember when he told me that
his wife was waiting for us
i mean that all of a sudden started
making me think of a whole bunch of
different scenarios i think
i i think that when something happens
to me personally my brain automatically
starts hoping for the best
outcome and so my mind started thinking
of different scenarios that would
make maybe why he kidnapped me
understandable
or less horrific than maybe i originally
thought
and so when he said he had a wife
waiting for me i started thinking well
maybe they always wanted to have a child
and they couldn't have a child
and maybe that's why he kidnapped me or
maybe they had a daughter and she died
and i looked like her i mean that was
the direction that my mind started going
but as soon as i saw her
the first thing she did was she hugged
me which for a second you almost think
that that confirmed the direction my
mind was going in
but it didn't
it let me i mean it it let me know that
that she was dangerous
that she was not there to protect me
that she was not there to help me that
if i ever
crossed her in any way that i would be
sorry for it
did she say that verbally or was that
just the vibe that she gave
no she didn't say that that was just a
vibe okay so she was scary
yeah very what time of day would you say
this is roughly now with
your when you made it there so by the
time we made it there
uh it was i mean the sun was up it was
light outside by now
wow um so i think it was probably
6 30 7 o'clock in the morning okay
so he has like i'm assuming like a camp
set up in this place what was
what kind of living circumstances did
they have right so
it was i mean it was a camp but it was a
very
well prepared camp i mean like i said it
was up pretty high
up on one of these mountain sides and
you could see that there had been
considerable time
and effort gone into planning this camp
because
first of all it was very difficult to
get to and
beyond that it was it was very well
supplied i mean i remember
at one point wondering how on earth they
had gotten all this stuff up there
because it was hard to get there
just just running not carrying anything
but they had this they had part of the
mountainside leveled out which would
have taken a fair amount of
physical labor and they'd kind of built
up
a almost a retaining wall to
to hold the dirt in place so that it
would
um so that they would have this flat
area
and then they had a tent set up and it
was probably like a six-man tent
and then outside the tent they had gray
plastic tarps lying on the ground and
then they had some gray tarps hanging in
the trees
above the tarp so it almost was like a
sheltered
patio and they had
like a little propane gas um
stove set up um they had
up turned five gallon buckets to sit on
so at this point he's he's settling with
you
i guess in terms of the knife down he's
let you talk to his
wife so i mean it happened
almost seamlessly i mean this was very
clearly planned out as soon as
she hugged me she like with her arms
around me walked me inside the tent
and zipped up the door us
closed and i mean i didn't know what he
was doing at that point i just knew that
she had brought me inside the tent
she'd sat me down on this upturned
bucket there was
all sorts of bedding and pillows lying
on the ground in there
and i remember there was this little
small
blue plastic basin
tub that she had brought in and she
took my shoes off and she put my feet in
the water and i just
i mean i remember just being hunched
over and just crying not paying too much
attention
to what she was doing but then i
remember she started to reach for my
my buttons on my pajamas to try to take
them off
and uh i i mean i was
i was very shy
i definitely was not comfortable with
her doing that i remember just grabbing
hold
of my pajamas um
clamping my elbows down next to my torso
so that she
she couldn't take them off and i
remember she kept trying and i remember
just crying
and asking her why was she doing this
she didn't have to
she kept saying she needed a sponge
bathed me she needed to clean me i
remember telling her i wasn't dirty i'd
showered last night before i went to bed
um and i just i remember just asking her
to leave me alone
begging her to leave me alone and she
wouldn't stop
and i remember finally at one point she
became
so frustrated with me that she said to
me
that if i didn't let her undress me and
sponge bathe me
she would have emmanuel the man who had
kidnapped me
come in and he would rip my clothes from
me
and i remember no matter how much i
didn't want her
to undress me i really
did not want him to come anywhere near
me
um so at that point i told her that
if she really wanted me to change i
could change myself
and i was a big girl and
um that i could do it myself so she
finally passed me this
long robe it was like a tunic robe it
wasn't like when you wrap around
yourself
you had to pull it on over your head and
i put that on and then i took off my
pajamas underneath
so all right so uh are you thinking
about
what's going to happen next at this
point are you aware of
his intentions or was that still unclear
i still at that point had no idea what
was going to happen
next and i i mean i just
it was so such a contrast
such a stark contrast from the life that
i had led
even up until just a few hours earlier
yeah
i mean i just couldn't even imagine why
this i mean they were they were a couple
why this man and this woman
would want to kidnap me a 14 year old
girl
um i just and then to make me wear
this strange tunic i mean why
what could they possibly want from me
what could they possibly want from my
family
how how long in that space of time was
it before
um you started experiencing him
trying to force himself on you and those
sort of things was it
i was thinking these guys might have
released you know
knowing some of the story i didn't
realize it was so fast
i mean he never verbatim said this
uh to me but i heard him trying to plan
other kidnappings so
i know he did the same for me um but
that she needed to be ready
for me there she needed to have this
basin of water where she was going to
wash me and clean me and essentially
prepare the lamb for slaughter um
prepare me for him and as soon as she
was done with that i mean there would be
next to no talking done um there'd be no
i mean as soon as she was done she would
leave the tent she would go out
and he would come in and that's exactly
what happened as soon as she was done
she picked up my pajamas picked up my
underwear picked up my shoes
got up and walked out of the tent um and
as soon as she was out of the tent he
walked into the tent
he had changed out of the dark sweat
clothes that he had worn
when he kidnapped me and um then
he uh
then he had put on a long tunic just
like the one that i've been forced to
wear
and um then he came in and he knelt down
next to me
and honestly i wasn't paying too much
attention
just because i uh
i mean i just been kidnapped
the most shocking thing more more than
what i
could have ever anticipated had just
happened so i wasn't really paying a
whole ton of attention to what he was
saying and what he was doing right off
the bat
but i i remember very clearly thinking
that i
needed to pay attention to what he had
to say because
um there might be some clue or some hint
as to how i could escape or why he was
doing this
or how i could get a message to my
family
something mm-hmm oh sorry my computer is
about to die
let me just no all right you take your
time let me grab my
power cord of course
thanks again by the way i really do
appreciate you uh
talking with me like this because it is
um
i'm a bit i don't want to say the wrong
thing if i'm honest with you do you know
what i mean
um honestly if there was ever someone
to mess up with it would be me because
okay i appreciate that really not
i have been asked every question you can
be asked okay and i don't get offended
that easy
well i'm coming from the right place
just so you know i really do want to be
respectful
um and yeah like in terms of you being
in this
situation you're describing um
you're in this tent and this man is
saying these things to you and
i'm trying to put myself in your head
yeah you're 14 years old and
you're in shock about what's just
happened but then on the other hand
you're trying to pay attention and focus
on what he's telling you
and i am assuming not long after that is
when the first
um time happens where he forces himself
on you
um i don't i don't want it i don't want
to ask certain questions and make you
feel uncomfortable i'm sure you've had
like you say you've had it all before i
i guess um what do you feel comfortable
sharing from that and and
and how was that that night
um so i mean i'm i am
i am perfectly fine to talk about it um
and i
actually feel like it's pretty important
to talk about it because
for so many victims there is so much
shame involved
even though at the end of the day you
know there's only one person
to blame and perpetrator every time
i mean it just it doesn't matter what
clothes you wear or clothes you don't
wear
doesn't matter where you go doesn't
matter if you're drunk or you're sober
at the end of the day it's the person
who decides to rape whose fault it is
so um i'm i'm fine to talk about it
um and it was terrifying i mean i
remember sitting there and
kind of picking up from where i left off
uh
thinking that i need to listen to what
he had to say
so i could find some clue or some hint
as to
why this was happening how i could
escape
and i really only heard one thing
and my guess is that it was probably the
worst thing that he could have said
or the worst thing in my opinion that he
could have said and that's when he said
that um
i was now his wife
and i mean this just seemed like
something i don't know
straight out of crazy
he had he said he already claimed
someone else is his wife
i was young enough to be his daughter
maybe even his granddaughter
i mean i was 14.
i hadn't even you know i
barely hit puberty like i hadn't even
had a period yet
like why would someone marry
a child or claim claim
a child as as their wife how could they
do that
i remember just being so disgusted and
just shocked and grossed out i remember
just screaming
out no and he looked at me and he said
if you ever scream like that again i'll
kill you
and i remember telling him then that he
had to realize this this wasn't okay
that
he had no legal authority to do that
that i was still a child that i was only
14 that um i couldn't even say yes
even if i wanted to i mean i remember i
got
so desperate to give myself some more
time
in hopes of someone rescuing me i
finally got to the point of
after giving every excuse that i could
possibly give
i finally got to the point of saying
well
well we should at least get to know each
other first
um i mean just trying to buy
any time at all anytime anything
and nothing that i said
made him pause or stop um
except well except when i told him that
i hadn't even had a period yet
he stopped and he yelled out to um the
woman he called her hapsaba
and he said pepsi boy she hasn't had a
period is it still okay
and um she yelled back yeah it's still
okay
and uh at that point i was just like
what is what's still okay and i
remember just having this thought come
to my mind and then he kept saying over
and over
it's now time to consummate our marriage
and i just remember thinking
okay first of all you need to stop
saying we're married because we're not
and consummate what does he even mean by
that
consummate our marriage and uh
that's when i kind of had this thought
of what he what he could mean and i
remember thinking
he means sex he means
raping me but that can't happen to me
that those things don't happen in my
world
those things they happen on the news
they happen to people that i don't know
and i mean naively i thought they
happened to
you know people who are out partying
people who are
women who you know aren't wearing
clothes or who are walking down dark
alleyways by
by themselves they don't happen to
little girls asleep in their bed
and at home and
uh i mean i found out
that yeah it does happen because it just
it just didn't matter what i said
uh he forced me on the ground i mean i
thought that if i
rolled onto my stomach i mean i thought
i was pretty naive i thought sex could
only happen in one position
where i thought both people i thought
like the actual
like anatomy of sex people had to be
facing each other so i remember in my
little 14 year old mind thinking that if
i rolled onto my stomach
that he couldn't rape me and of course
that wasn't true
um i i remember just
just begging and pleading and crying and
being
in so much pain
um and it just it just didn't matter i
mean even
while he was raping me i remember just
asking him can he be done
can he be done can he be done and
he'd just be like oh not yet not yet
just a little more and
um then when he was finished he just
kind of stood up and smiled and
turned around walked out of the tent
like it wasn't a big deal
but for me i it was a big deal it was a
huge deal i mean
like physically i was in a lot of pain
but i mean i'd also just been kidnapped
um
i had just had my life ripped away from
me
i i was scared i was alone i was
i nothing in my life
had prepared me for that moment i don't
think there was anything that could have
prepared me
for what happened truth be told though
um i mean i just
and at that point i don't actually know
if i fell asleep or if i passed out
but one of the two happened and my next
memory was
opening my eyes and there he was again
and this time he was wrapping a piece of
metal cable
around my ankle and then not just
twisting bolts into place but crushing
them
into place so that i couldn't escape no
matter what and
that metal cable was connected to that
first metal cable that i saw strung
between the two trees so
it was just um i could sort of slide
the little cable i was bolted to along
this longer cable and i could reach you
know i could reach about 12 feet
and that was about it so at this point
you've passed out
and at the exact time i'm guessing
judging by the time scale you gave me
earlier
your family are now waking up and
realizing
you're not there or because your sister
was kind of aware if i'm right and
thinking that you'd gone so
she um she said that she
watched that she said that she was awake
when i was kidnapped
that she watched and that she heard him
take me out of our bedroom
and she kept waiting to hear the alarm
go off as well
um so she thought he was still in the
house
for a long time we had this old
grandfather clock and it goes off every
15 minutes
and she said she heard the grandfather
clock go off twice
so probably a half hour had passed
and that's when she uh
she had this like it was her blanket it
was her blankie that she had from when
she was a baby she
she had wrapped it not just around her
shoulders but even over her head
and she had to
um cross the top of
our staircase downstairs to go to my
parents room my parents room was on the
other side of the house
she said she still thought that he was
maybe in the house because she had never
heard
she never heard her door open she never
heard the alarm go off
but she went in and she first went to my
dad's side and then she went around to
my mom's side
and she woke my parents up and she said
elizabeth is gone and my parents were
like what are you what are you talking
about elizabeth isn't gone
and so she said she's she's gone
and so my parents got up to go check and
i mean because my sister and i we shared
a bed
like she's not the best person to share
a bed with she
hogs the covers blocks the space she's a
hot sleeper
like she kicks and so it wouldn't have
been that uncommon for me to
i don't know go into my baby brother's
room he slept in the crib but there's
also a little bed in there
that sometimes i'd go and sleep in there
because i got sick of being kicked or
i'd go down into the kitchen and sleep
on the sofa
so my parents started going around and
checking
all the bedrooms all the rooms and my
little sister said
you're not going to find her a man came
and took her
and she was almost nine years old she
was still
eight she was almost nine years old at
the time and
my mom ran into the kitchen and
we had a like a bank of lights like
like it was multiple lights all on the
same switch and you could just like slam
your whole hand against them and all the
lights would come on
and so my mom ran into the kitchen and
slammed
her hand against this bank of lights and
her eye went
straight to that one narrow kitchen
window and she saw how the screen had
been cut
and that's when she just yelled to my
dad ed call 9-1-1
elizabeth is gone someone has taken her
so it was
actually really not that long
after i had been taken i mean a half
hour
probably maybe maybe 45 minutes an hour
at the most before my parents knew that
i was gone
and this is the thing in the uk um
this i i guess unless people have
stumbled across um
some of the videos made about this story
but um
we people might not understand but this
was huge
news in america i mean this was
everywhere
people connected with you because you
had such an angelic
perfect little face that i think um you
know it was everywhere on the media
in the news this was the biggest
missing child case since charles
lindbergh's baby was kidnapped
and this was the biggest man search
manhunt ever
ever put on for anyone um i mean
within the first day they had over ten
thousand volunteers
coming to search for me i mean just
and it was it's been interesting because
uh i mean i've spoken with my brothers
and my parents
since obviously but my older brother i
remember talking to him and he was just
like
he's like it was just amazing i mean
there were so many people people
showed up who looked like they could be
kidnappers themselves
but they showed up and they were
honestly sometimes
he was just like you just could not
judge anyone
because everyone was there to help and
they would have done anything to bring
you home he's like there was not a tree
that did not have your a light blue
balloon on it
for you or a blue ribbon on it for you
or a missing poster i mean
everybody's windows of their houses had
your face in it
every light pole had your face on every
grocery store had your missing
poster on it he's like you know it
seemed like
a day didn't go by without your face
being all over the news
or newspapers or magazines he was like
it was
it was everywhere
it's amazing how you weren't that far
away and yet all those people still were
so unfortunate not to find you um
despite trying so hard
um did you ever uh find out why they
managed to it was it just because he was
so well hidden in that strange place
that he'd managed to get you
it was very very difficult to get to
years later um i mean when i first wrote
my my book my story that kind of tells
the whole story of what happened
i did this big interview with meredith
fiera
on nbc and um
they wanted to hike back to where i was
held captive
and i said yeah that's fine like how far
is that like it's like
it's just over three miles i was like
but just so you know
it's very difficult to get to like it's
not it's not an easy hike and
the camera crew they were they were so
nice but they kind of were joking around
they're like no it's okay he just ran a
marathon last week i think he'll be fine
and so i was like okay i was like but
just you know just just be prepared like
it
it'll be a challenge so like no we'll be
fine
promise and so i was like okay so the
next day
we go to hike up to where i was held
captive at
and um i mean it was hard
you for you wait up through this stream
this
muddy muddy stream and then you're
fighting your way through
brush and scrub oak and poison ivy and
stinging nettle
and i mean no one in their right mind
would fight their way through all of
this to get up there and then once you
finally get up to
this small
tiny little valley area
you have to then go almost straight up
this mountain site i mean it's
incredibly steep
and you almost have to
get on your hands and feet to make it up
without falling without sliding down it
um i mean it is a it is a rugged hard
climb
and so we got i don't know maybe halfway
and finally one of the camera crew
members just sat down they're like
i can't go any farther i'm done
and uh that proves everything doesn't it
yeah yeah and i was like okay that's
like it's fine but the rest of them like
okay we gotta keep going
and they're like can you just tell us
where it's at and because we want to get
your reaction walking in here and i was
like well
i was like this is not my first time
back i've been back here like
i had to show the fbi i've had a show
like i showed my parents like i've been
back
here before like it doesn't it doesn't
bother me
coming back to this place um this place
didn't hurt me it was the people that
hurt me
that's a very strong-minded approach
because you know a lot of people
wouldn't feel that way so credit here
um going going back to the the
the falling asleep at camp while
this big search has been conducted for
you did he settle into some
sort of new normal for you pretty
quickly
or was it did it start off different and
then find its own way of becoming
normality
no i think it i mean he kept
he kept pretty in character the whole
time that i was with him
um he
he was very he was highly manipulative
and very very devious and he had found
that the best way to manipulate people
and to get what he wanted and to justify
anything that he did
was through religion and i think
probably most people would agree that
to some extent religion has always been
uh a sensitive subject
certainly in america at that time it was
a very sensitive subject i mean 9 11
the twin towers that had only happened
not even a whole year earlier that had
happened
eight months nine months earlier before
and so it was still it was still pretty
fresh
um what was his faith in particular
his faith was doing what he wanted and
saying god told him to do it
so he'd say things to me like
like you should be grateful
that i took you because i rescued you
god chose you for me
i didn't want to do this but god told me
to do it because you're special
and the rest of the world is so wicked
that he needed someone who was pure
to come and be my wife and have
my children so that we can there can
still be goodness in this world
um i mean that's how he he justified
everything and
he'd say things like um
but you know what for as innocent as you
are even you are still so wicked and it
and you're so prideful you need to know
that you are no better than anyone
else so god has told me that you need to
experience um you need to experience
alcohol you need to experience smoking
cigarettes
you need to experience going naked
all day you need to experience what it
is
for a husband and wife to have a
loving intimate relationship so
what we're going to do is you are going
to watch hebsebot and i
have have sex the real the way a real
couple
makes love and then when we're done
it's going to be your turn and if you
don't do this
first of all god has commanded you to do
this and if you don't
you won't get any food and you won't get
any water
and you won't get to sleep you won't get
to do
anything until you follow through with
what we tell you
and so that was really how he
manipulated everyone that's how he got
exactly what he wanted
i mean just everywhere he went
i mean the guy was clearly a sick person
evil just pure evil and
as as these weeks went by what was what
is sort of a normal day like
waking up at the camp and how do you
know your food
that sort of thing and how they talk to
you um
i mean i didn't get food unless they
gave food to me
i didn't get water unless they gave
water to me
um they would
i mean he he
really lived this
facade to the full extent of him being
this
holy man this prophet um
he lived it as as much as he could
because it was such a powerful tool
in uh i mean
in manipulating everyone and justify
what he did and that's how he
that's how he really manipulated his his
wife
his real wife not me um because i think
that
she was raised very religious she'd been
very religious her whole life
she came from an abusive first marriage
she had six kids in her first marriage
and then when she met him he was the one
that was telling her that she was
special
he was the one that was telling her that
she was
that she was good and that she was
righteous and that
god valued her as a daughter and that
um that she had a special place in
heaven
waiting for her but that she would have
to bear many trials that would be hard
for her in order for her to
um obtain this this special place
and that's how he controlled her because
she
it was easier for her to believe what he
told her
than to admit the truth because to admit
the truth she would have to admit
that she is in fact a very evil
person um to allow
what was happening to me to go on
and so sh it was just easier for her to
believe what he said and so she did
and that's why she was able to step
aside and let him rape me
and why she allowed him to
you know withhold water or food from me
and so an average day
um would begin i mean
he'd probably
wake up and and rape me
and then he would like open up the bible
and he'd say now it's time for us to you
know
learn the word of god and so he'd read
from the bible
and then um he'd say okay now we need to
pray
and like he'd read for a long time
and then he'd pray for a long time
and honestly sometimes like it was
it was long i think i
probably fell asleep a lot
um and then by the time
all of that was done um
he would pull out the food whatever food
he
deemed was okay for me to have and
um then he'd say that he needed to bless
the food
because um all food that we ate would
would be a sacrament
so then he would bless the food then i'd
finally be allowed to eat whatever it
was he gave me
and then um the rest of the day
would be filled with him
talking i mean honestly sometimes i
thought
maybe talking was worse than being raped
because he would just go
on and on and on
forever and
then at some point it was usually
necessary to get water and we would have
to hike down
the steep the steep part of the mountain
where we were hiding that down to the
smaller valley
and down probably half a mile to where
this
the stream came right up out of the
ground and that's where we would collect
our water from
and we would collect them just in gallon
jugs
and he had these two bags that he would
tie the tops together
and there'd be two gallons in front and
two gallons in back
and then he'd sling him over his
shoulder or
or me he'd have me carry it up and then
we'd scramble back
up to this hiding this hidden camp and
he started to try to dig this
underground
house i mean i say underground house but
it's not like
the house house it's basically a big
hole in the ground
with um logs and branches thrown over
the top to create a roof
because he thought that eventually one
day we would stay there year round
so sometimes he'd have me dig in this
hole
um sometimes he'd just sit and talk
sometimes he'd rape me again
sometimes he'd say that god had revealed
new revelation to him and
he'd thought of some new fantasy he
wanted to
act out i don't know i mean
it was it was it was a pretty horrific
time
yeah like i empathize with you so much
like i can't imagine how bad that must
have been um
being beholden as someone who's just
such an evil crazy person
and clearly just in love with himself um
it made me smirk a bit i'll be honest
when you said he used to go on and on
and on because i can really feel
how mind-numbing this idiot's [__]
must have been for you to listen to
uh would it always be a religious chat
or would he talk about anything else
he would talk about whatever he wanted
to um he
loved talking about
like his life prior to him kidnapping me
and sort of the different i guess
he did he would tend to put a real like
his
personal theology theological spin on it
but um he would kind of paint whatever
he
had experienced you know with religion
and say how god led him here
god led him there he got so drunk and
had sex with so many women and
and it was god's you know gift to him
for you know for all the future
hardships he was gonna have to go
through
or so he did do it a lot but he was also
actually very smart i mean he sat down
and explained to me how our entire legal
system worked
um politics he talked to me about
history
um i mean of course it was a skewed
skewed version of it
but he still talked about it uh did this
might have a job before he just decided
to adopt people
oh he had multiple jobs but probably one
of
his most reputable jobs was he worked
for a company called oc tanner
i'd almost say the company's hobby
is that they also do jewelry and
they make olympic rings they make a lot
of the olympic medals
at least they did for the salt lake 2002
winter olympics
um and so he was he had actually been a
die cutter
so he would help create fit the molds
um for these pieces of jewelry
or medallions or awards to to be
cast in um so i mean he did have
different jobs over the years and that
was probably one of his more
reputable jobs did you have any idea
or did he mention why one day he decided
to go and
live in the woods like because that is
very strange for a start isn't it
uh well i mean i didn't start off just
going from a house straight to the woods
first
so it was the house and then they went
to um
a big fifth-wheel trailer
and then they downsized from that where
he
built like a they called it a hand house
so it was like a little tiny house on
wheels
that he and wanda barzi the woman's real
name
that they would just walk and pull
around behind them
and then they went from that to pulling
a hand cart around and then
after that uh that's when they
went from the hand cart to the woods
and actually initially they had a teepee
that they'd set up
and then they decided that the teepee
was too conspicuous and that they
couldn't take me to the teepee
and so that's when they went even
farther back up into the mountains
and found this hidden secluded area
where they then built this hidden
campsite that they took me to
once they kidnapped me we stayed at this
this hidden camp for the first
three four months and then um
fall started coming and i mean it's cold
in utah we have snow there's a reason
why our license plates say greatest snow
on earth it's cold yeah
freezing and we were not prepared
in any way to survive a winter
in the mountains so
um they he had this he called it a lower
camp he called it the base camp
that was much closer to
the popular trail that people would go
on
um that you had to go on before you took
like this hidden
cut-off trail that he'd used to get back
so
this base camp was much closer to that
area and so he moved us down there
and he started going down into salt lake
almost daily
to try to save enough money
beg i mean he called it he called it
ministering and he'd say that
god's true disciples would recognize who
he was and that they would give him
money
and he'd only call uh people who gave
him money
uh true disciples and so he'd go down
and he'd beg for money
or as he liked to say he'd minister for
money but about
once a week that he would allow me to go
down into salt lake
and i was always fully covered i mean i
still had to wear this long tunic
i had this headdress on
um that covered all my hair and then i
had a veil across my face and then i had
a second veil um that was sheer
that would still cover my eyes and and
my mouth
area and um actually before though that
second veil that shear bell was put on
um i he had taken me down into salt lake
to try to figure out where we were going
to go to next
um and we'd gone to the public library
and we were looking at maps of the
united states and that's when he decided
that we should go to california
for the winter and um actually we were
approached by a homicide detective
in the library and um he
he had approached my captor and he just
said you know we've had some calls in
and um you know we just need to check we
need to check them out
um you know who's this who's with you
why is she with you why is she covered
all these kinds of things and
he was he was very convincing when he
wanted to be
so he he's like this is my daughter you
know this is part of our religion
and the police officer said well can i
convert to your religion for like
10 minutes just so i can see your face
so i can tell these people who
are calling in about her that it's not
it's not who we're looking for and my
captor was like
i'm i'm sorry but no even if you
converted to our religion you still
wouldn't be allowed to see her face
the only people that will ever see her
her face
are her family and her future husband
and that's it i'm sorry it would be very
disrespectful and degrading if i allowed
you to see her face
and i mean that homicide detective
believed him
and he turned around and he walked away
and i i mean believe me when i say
i wanted to scream i wanted to be
rescued
it was not fun i did not want to stay
with him it was not a vacation
but for so many months
no one had been there to protect me no
one had been there to
rescue me no one had been there to stop
him
from doing anything he wanted to me so
when he would threaten me and say
i will kill you if you don't do exactly
what i tell you to do
i will kill your family if you ever try
to run away
if you ever do anything i don't want you
to do i
i believed him and he got to the point
of feeling like he was invincible
because
he'd bring back missing posters and
missing flyers and newspaper articles
to this hidden campsite when he'd go
down into salt lake for food
and he'd bring them back and he'd show
them to me and he'd laugh about him and
he'd say the whole city is looking for
you
but no one is ever going to find you
because i have you
and it seemed like he was right i mean i
remember there were times when there
were helicopters
that were so low that were flying so low
overhead that the trees would shake that
the tent
would shake under the pressure from the
wind that they would make
um i mean i even remember one time
hearing my name
being yelled and i mean that time he had
pulled out his knife and he said if you
say anything i'll kill you
if anyone finds us i'll kill them and
it'll be your fault
you will have killed someone and
i just i was never given a reason to
doubt
that he wouldn't follow through with
everything that he said
so even though there was a homicide
detective standing right
in front of me and more than anything i
wanted to be rescued
it didn't feel like he could resk me it
didn't feel like he could
save me or protect me from these two
monsters who had had me
not to mention as soon as this man
approached
uh as soon as this homicide detective
approached the table
um wanda barzee who was sitting next to
me she had just clamped her hand down on
my leg and it was like she was trying to
tell me
remember what we're capable of and we
will kill you
and if we don't kill you we will send
someone to kill you so
not only did i feel responsible to
survive myself but i also felt
responsible to protect my family
which is why i didn't
scream out and everything up until that
point i told you that this man was
deadly evil and you know not worth
taking the risk on
so he wrecked me every day right
multiple times often like
he had no problem with holding water
from me or food from me
i mean i went a week once without eating
anything
jesus i mean he had he had no problem
doing those kinds of things to me so
why would you question it
i didn't have a relationship with police
i've never come into contact with police
before so
how did i know what they're capable of
yeah
you obviously you mentioned about being
raped and about
um previously had a new fantasy that he
wanted to enact
i'm scared to ask this to be honest um
did you find a way to
mentally as best you could try and
switch
off or did it continuously get worse
with these crazy new fantasies that he
was
having or whatever well i finally got to
the point of thinking that i'd hit rock
bottom because every time i did
he'd find some new way to make me change
my mind and think well
that this is that definitely was not
rock bottom this is definitely rock
bottom and then it'd happen again
and it'd be worse so i finally stopped
thinking that i'd hit rock bottom
but i i feel like the best way to
describe
uh how i got through it was i i became
like
like a hard-boiled egg um that i created
this hard shell
outside myself that you could roll me
around whatever direction
and i'd be inside protected but even if
um even if that shell was broken
i still had this layer of insulation
that yeah it was a lot more sensitive
and it
was much much easier to damage
but even that area was not where i lived
that i was
at my very core and that's the best way
i can describe how it was
that's a great way of describing it um
and
at all at this time as well you're
you're you're going through some
extreme pain but your family are also
going through
extreme heartache
i'm sure you've talked to them since
then what was that experience like of
that worrying
just dread that they were going through
um i mean my
mom said that the only reason why she
could get out of bed in the morning
was because my baby brother would come
in and he would tell her that he was
hungry
and that was the only way she could get
out of bed in the morning
um that
i mean he was he was three years old
when i was kidnapped and
so that's that's how it how it initially
was was
being there just to keep my other
siblings alive
physically i mean i know a lot of them
were sent to live with relatives
for the first initial few weeks because
the fbi took over our home
they were you know collecting
fingerprints they were collecting hair
they were collecting everything they
could
they took so many of my possessions into
custody
uh just the entire house just
i mean just turned into a
a crime scene and so a lot of my
siblings were sent to live with friends
and family
um my parents they were put under
immense pressure and just i mean
people said some truly awful things
about my parents that my parents had
killed me
and that they had um plastered my
remains
inside the walls of our home jesus
um that my parents were the ones that
killed me or they had sold me
um just just awful things i mean it got
to the point that my dad had
a uh a full-blown mental breakdown where
he did have to be hospitalized
and finally my mom said she got to this
point where
she she didn't
want to
give up but
she also could not continue the way that
she was
and she had five other young children
that needed her
and so she said that she i mean she
wanted the searches to continue she
wanted everything to continue
but that she needed to still be a mother
to her five
other children and so she had to get to
this point where
where it was just easier to believe that
i was dead
then to uh
keep holding on to believing that i was
alive
and still try to be a mom to my other
brothers and my sister
when they were all going through a hard
time too
nothing pulls a family together like a
mother's love so
credit uh and who could blame her for
whatever she was thinking in that point
i guess
did the police find any evidence that
linked back to
emmanuel no right
did they ever suspect the family or did
they ever i mean
yeah they they suspected my parents i
mean that's that's
as a police officer and i don't blame
him i don't blame him for a second
because
most of the time when children are
kidnapped
it's a family member it's someone that
you know i mean
it's i think it's over 90 of the time
i think it's even higher than 90 but
it's someone that you know
it's not it's not a stranger which is
what makes my abduction
different because it was a stranger but
so yeah absolutely my family was
my parents were under scrutiny my
brothers
were under scrutiny i mean my older
brother he's only like 18 months older
than me
and then my brother who's just after me
i mean he's
two and a half three years younger than
me and they were put they were giving
them
lie detector tests i mean my brother my
younger brother was 11 years old and
they were having him take a lie detector
test
and they thought that he might be
capable of of doing something to me
i mean my sister she was the only one
that saw anything so they interviewed
her
and interviewed her they tried to
hypnotize her
um they they just tried to
get as much information out of her as
they possibly could
and then the ironic thing is is that it
was actually her
who realized who it was who kidnapped me
and when she finally did realize who it
was
people didn't take her seriously i mean
she
she said she had been looking at the
guinness book of world records
and for whatever reason she like flipped
the page and there was this picture of
this extremely muscular woman on there
and she looked at it she's just like i
know who kidnapped elizabeth
and so she went and told my parents who
had kidnapped me
and um i mean he was a stranger he had
seen me one time okay maybe twice before
he'd seen me out school close shopping
with my mom
the fall prior to him kidnapping me
he had he didn't ask for money from my
mom he asked for work and at that point
in time
he was clean-shaven his clothes looked
clean he just looked like he was
you know down on his luck and my mom
she never gives out information ever but
this one time
she's like why don't you call my husband
he might have some work that you could
do
and so he called up my dad and that was
i mean at that point in time
just that one time seeing me out school
clothes shopping with my mom
um was he had decided that in there that
i was the girl he wanted to kidnap
and uh he had only followed through
calling my dad
asking for work to find out where we
lived so my dad told him
yeah you know i have um some weeding and
some roof work that i need done
um you know why don't you come and do it
and so he came just one time
to find out where we lived did some
weeding did some
i think he did some homework i don't
know i mean i was in junior high i
wasn't paying that much attention to him
uh when my mom went to pay him he had
said that his name was
emmanuel and my little sister had heard
that and then all those months later
honestly it was probably
probably about a year later maybe even
longer
when she opened up that guinness book of
world records that she was like it was
emmanuel
emmanuel is the one that came and took
her and she said that to my dad
and my dad and a couple of my brothers
went to the police station to try to
get a police sketch done of him and they
did the police sketch but they didn't
they didn't want to release it or
anything they didn't really want to
take this lead that seriously and
then it was my dad and
john walsh from america's most wanted he
was the
show host and i mean he has his own
tragic story about his son adam walsh
being kidnapped and murdered
but they were on larry king live
and they were the ones that event that
showed this
picture that said who he was and that
was really a turning point
in the case because ever and everyone
the police the fbi they were all a bit
upset with them for releasing this
image releasing this um detail
that it could be this person because
they're like no it's not him like
no but actually that was really what led
to me being rescued
yeah that thank god that they did that
then and ignored the fbi
um how how did that lead to the rescue
and
the freedom for you i believe it was
actually some of brian mitchell's
family members because that's his real
name that was emmanuel's real name was
brian mitchell
some of his family members saw it saw
i don't know if they saw the actual
episode i'm not 100
sure of the exact details but to my
understanding um some of his family
members saw what was going on i think
maybe it was a sister
and they called in and they gave a
real picture and they
said oh yeah lately i mean nobody's seen
him for a little while
but the last few sightings of him
because he'd really cut off all ties
with his family
um you know he he was with two women it
wasn't just
one woman there's an older woman and
then there was a younger woman but none
of us know who she is
and meanwhile we had been in california
we
ended up hitchhiking back to salt lake
and that's when people
i think it was about three different
individuals who called the police within
less than about
five minutes of each other saying that
they think that they
just they found they think they saw
brian mitchell and that they think that
they just saw elizabeth smart
and ultimately that's what led to my
rescue
yeah can you kind of describe for me
what those uh
moments were like when you finally knew
you were safe
um so honestly i did not know that i was
safe
uh after i'd been separated from my
captors after i'd been taken to the
police station
um i'd actually been handcuffed on the
way over which made me think that i was
in trouble
but when i finally made it to the police
station i was brought into this little
room
and they they didn't unhandcuff me and
i still didn't know what was happening i
didn't know i was safe
until the door just burst open
and my dad came running into the room
and it was when he started hugging me
that
i didn't know what was gonna happen next
but i at least knew that it was gonna be
okay
because my dad was there and he was
never gonna let anyone hurt me again
the way these two people had hurt me the
last nine months
the emotion must have been unbelievable
in that moment to know that your dad had
you and everything was okay
what was he like he was crying
i mean i didn't even it happened so fast
from when he burst open the door to him
hugging me
it honestly took a second for me to
respond
it took a second for the dots to connect
because i just i didn't know what was
coming next i mean i remember thinking
that if they thought that i was innocent
wouldn't they have taken me home
wouldn't they have let me call my
parents at least wouldn't they let me
talk to my parents or at least tell me
what was going to happen next but
they hadn't said anything i've been
brought to this little small room i
actually thought it was a cell
i don't actually think it was a cell
though now it's just this little tiny
room
and um i mean it seemed to have this
really big heavy metal door
and i uh i just didn't i didn't know
what was gonna happen next and so when
my dad
almost appeared out of thin air um it
was
like it was a pretty big shock the way
you're describing it like it just shows
the state of mind he had you in
like at that point of just never knowing
what is safety like never trusting
you know and i guess the police didn't
help because it doesn't sound like they
were that reassuring to you
when the police actually intervened and
you actually had that little moment
where they were taking you away from
them um
i'm assuming he tried to talk his way
out of it as he always did
when they first started questioning us i
was in the middle
and i had a captor on either side of me
and then
um then they separated me from them
and they started to question me on my
own which is when i eventually told them
who i was when i admit
who i was but i was already separated
from my captors so i didn't hear the
ongoing questions
um or dialogue that was going on between
my captors and the police at that point
and we were put into separate cars and
um
yeah i i didn't see them again how long
between that moment and the trial
for this guy to be convicted was there
how many years
or months was it was almost a decade it
was
eight years wow why so long
i was i will say this
i i hope that the uk courts are better
than the american courts because it's
not a victim-friendly place
um i can respect
the belief that innocent until proven
guilty
but in my case i didn't feel like there
was anything to prove i felt like it was
already proven
it was obvious it was evident he never
tried to deny it
he had admitted it from the beginning i
mean
this is the easiest case in the world um
but i mean his defense
was always whether or not he was um
it was like a plea of insanity but it
was
whether he was he needed to be
coherence not the right word
they do this though don't they these
criminals they they do sick things which
well thought out well planned out
clearly
they're not like you know mentally ill
because they've managed to
you know plan all this and done it for
months and then they play
insanity and it's like it's [__]
but they so he was at a state hospital
for a long time and they were always
like well we need to make sure that he
is
uh why can i not think of that word this
is almost this is embarrassing
no it's cool they basically want to know
these people
are fit to go to court isn't it yeah
exactly and so
he was fit to do the crime so i'm pretty
sure he's all right
thank you yeah um but it went on so long
that actually it was before the statute
of limitations
in utah was done away with on sex crimes
um and so it was still standing and
uh or at least the crimes that he was
getting um
charged with it was still standing so
almost five years
had expired and i remember getting a
phone call
from the u.s attorney asking me to come
and meet with him
and i went and met with him and he
asked me if i wanted to
leave the case in the state courts or if
i wanted to move it to the federal
courts
and he told me that if it remained in
the state courts
that um he probably
[Music]
you know he they wouldn't just let him
go he would probably go to a state
hospital but eventually
they would release him and they would be
obligated to release him because he was
never charged with anything
or did i want to press federal charges
and i was like
of course i want to press federal
charges
jesus um and so then it took
time for um the federal courts to get
their case together
but i mean also his defense i mean they
were great at able to
grade it able to drag their feet
and it was always about whether or not
he would be
mentally sound to stand trial to
understand
everything that was going on but i mean
his ultimate master plan which actually
worked pretty well for him i mean
had it stayed in the state courts it
would have worked completely for him
was he just didn't cooperate with anyone
he just
ignored everyone he wouldn't speak to
anyone
i mean only when he saw benefit for
himself
would he do something which so in these
cases
he saw the greatest benefit to himself
was not cooperating
not allowing a case to be put together
against him
and uh um so it took a long time
i think it's ironic that they're asking
if he's going to be able to understand
how the court went when he was sitting
explaining them to you
in in the camp uh he knows fine well how
they work either tell you a thing or two
by the sounds of it
um and what you're yeah i did see a clip
of him online
singing in the court definitely trying
to play act
to come across as mentally unstable as
possible
i know you said you never seen him again
does that mean you didn't see him in
court
oh i saw him in court i mean i didn't
see him
as a child again so yes yeah so by the
time you see him again
um you're now a grown woman um still a
young woman but
a grown woman what was that feeling
like now i didn't know how i was going
to react
i wasn't curious to see him i was
curious how i was gonna feel
seeing him because i just i just didn't
know
what to expect i didn't know if he was
gonna stand up to me
and stand and turn and look at me and
start like
yelling repentance at me like repent you
repent you for the kingdom of heaven is
at hand kind of stuff
um because i mean he did that to other
people before so was he gonna do that to
me
or i just didn't i didn't know what
to expect i didn't know what to
anticipate
yeah i was nervous but then he walked in
and he he'd walk in
and he'd always have his eyes closed and
he'd be shackled
and he'd be holding his head up like
like he was a martyr
and he'd be singing and they'd be they'd
be hymns they'd be
religious songs that he'd be singing
every time that he'd walk in i mean you
would hear him start as soon as the
doors opened up that's when he'd start
singing
and then you'd actually hear him stop
singing once he'd been taken out of the
out of the courtroom but i mean he would
sing and sing until the judge would call
him to order
the judge would call him to order again
and then finally he'd say if you can
continue singing you know you will be
excused from the courtroom you'll be
taken to another room
where you will be able to watch uh court
proceedings on a monitor where you can
no longer disrupt the courtroom
and that's exactly what he wanted so he
kept singing and so he'd get escorted
out every day
you know i've had people do bad things
to me when i say them there's a
feeling in the pit of my stomach where
i'm like oh i i feel awful just even
looking at them
was there anything like that or were you
just ready for this
my feelings were were of disgust really
um just this
gross man this gross old man
i mean they're just i was just disgusted
by him and
i was disgusted by his antics and as i
sat there listening
i mean his defense they had so many
witnesses come up and
most the time i'd sit there and listen
to the witnesses and i think
how on earth is this helping his case
any
i mean all you hear is person after
person
basically testifying how this man has
destroyed
every life he's ever come into contact
with
and how manipulative he is and how
deceitful he is
and just how evil he is how can this be
helping your case
i mean honestly i lost a lot of respect
actually for his full
defense team the only person that walked
away
with his defense from his defense team
that i
had any respect left for was his
lead um attorney who at the very end of
the trial came up to me and he said
elizabeth he's like
i want you to know that i did the very
best job
that i could and he's like not because i
believe that this man is innocent or
because i believe that this man should
walk free
but because i never want for this to be
called a mistrial and for him to have a
chance to appeal it
and you have to go through this again do
you think that was the truth or was he
saying that for his own conscience
no i think that was the truth for him i
think that was absolutely the truth
makes you wonder what these lawyers go
through mentally at night when they
sleep and they realize that sometimes
they they do get people off you know
what i mean and it
you know these you know people who
defend child killers and all sorts of
things out there i don't know how they
do it
um to be fair it's a hard job you know i
get that
um looking back at that 10-year period
roughly between you being the girl who
was found to be in
the woman in the court mentally
how did you rebuild yourself after that
because that must have been
you know you're such a great speaker you
come across such a confident strong
and happy person and you've been through
something
worse than most people can ever even
imagine i just how did you do it
i mean it didn't happen overnight it was
definitely
a a big period of adjustment it was such
a shock to come home
and and think that my life would go back
to the way it was before i was kidnapped
and all of a sudden just everywhere i
went people
recognizing me people hugging me people
talking to me like they knew me
people telling me their worst
experiences
of their life people confiding in me
about what's happened to them
it was a major adjustment one that
it was honestly was hard to make because
i still wanted to go back to being who i
was before i was kidnapped
i still wanted to go back to being a
wallflower i mean i
i liked not not being recognized
i liked just blending in with everyone
else that was perfectly fine with me
you know it made me always sort of
double
question people's motives why are they
being nice to me
why are they being my friend why is he
asking me out on a date um
why you know why am i like
why am i being singled out is it because
i did something
like i did well on an assignment or i
um you know did like an
exceptional job on something or or is it
just because of my past
right um so i mean there was definitely
a lot
a lot a long time that i
i just bought struggled first of all
but also that i had a lot of doubts and
i had a lot of questions
and ultimately i got to this point where
i was like
i can never go back to who i once was as
much as i may want to go back
to who i was before i was kidnapped i
mean
brian mitchell wanda barzee they took
things away from me that i'll never get
back they took nine months of my life
that
i will never get back
and you know now coming back i'll never
just be able to go back to blending in
i will never just be able to
[Music]
be me again um so
i might as well get on with embracing
this and i might as well
do something with it i might as well try
to
make a difference and and i mean i know
what it's like to be raped i know what
it's like to be sexually abused i know
what it's like to be kidnapped and
to be hurt and to have your life ripped
away from you
i mean i know exactly what that's like
and
initially and i think probably most
victims would agree
that when these crimes happen to you you
feel like you're the only one it feels
like it's
extremely isolating it feels like
there's not another human being in this
world that could possibly understand
what you've been through physically but
also
mentally and emotionally and all of the
aftermath that
carries along with it um but then as i
you know was approached by so many
people i started to realize
wow actually i am not alone
there's actually
so many people who have
maybe not the exact same story but a
very
similar story maybe this needs to be
talked about a little bit more
maybe there is something that i can
actually do to help
cause and create change and that was
kind of the beginning of it
yeah i've got to credit you for taking
such a negative and
spinning it into the as big a positive
as you could
um and you know even even someone like
me
see a big tattooed guy and people think
you know this could never happen to me
and um
it i mean that what you went through was
never happened to me obviously but like
i had a near miss when i was a child
with a babysitter who
uh was rubbing himself and offered to
expose himself to me
and you know it can happen to anyone
and uh obviously women especially
um but yeah i've got so much admiration
for you
and to to go through what you went
through is is bad enough but to then be
turned into
a celebrity which is something you as
you said you wanted to be a wallflower
you never wanted to be
the the person everyone was looking at
and then i guess dealing with not just
all of the
everyone knowing you which i know from
experiences is can be awful sometimes
but also people feeling sorry for you
um which is a given now and i don't know
was that uh hard it would just here as
well because some people don't always
want that
you know what i mean some people just
want to get on with it i haven't really
let
um people feeling sorry get to me too
much because i understand where it comes
from
it comes from a place of genuine concern
it comes from a place of love it comes
from a place of
heartache i mean i i am to the point
where
i i cannot watch
uh it's very very rare that i watch any
kind of crime documentary
um that i i
don't want to watch um i mean
even movies as simple as finding nemo
the yeah the disney pixar movie um
i don't like that movie i don't want to
watch it
because i mean nemo is kidnapped
but then it makes it look like he has
this great time and makes all these
friends and
and it has a happy ending and that's not
how kidnapping really is
um i didn't go away and i didn't make
good friends
and it wasn't just this great time and
this great adventure
and um it was a horrific experience so
now i'm like i just want to watch happy
easy stupid stuff that i can turn
on and turn off at any point
um i mean like i i don't even know how
many times i watch the british baking
show
probably a thousand yeah
i mean with with tv being the way it is
now it is
um i mean netflix let's be honest it's
99 crime documentaries
so um it must be really difficult for
you in that regard
and i guess i never would have
considered that
i mean i just there's enough darkness in
the world
and you know now i have my own
non-profit the elizabeth smart
foundation and i have so many people
who have shared and disclosed their
stories to me that
i don't i don't need to fill up the rest
of my time
with that kind of darkness because i've
already first of all i've already lived
it
and then um i also work in it so
in my relaxation time i don't want to
fill it up with that anymore
and that i mean that even extends to
like game of thrones i mean
violence and rape i mean my husband was
watching and sometimes
you know i sit and i'd watch it with
them and sometimes i just feel like i
can't like i can't watch this anymore
like you need to turn on something else
i don't think he's a good sport and i
was like yeah he's like no problem he's
like
what do you want to watch friends i'm
like yeah that's great let's turn on
friends
um in that um recovery period i was
wondering
did you get any professional help
counselling etc so when i first got home
um i mean the day after i was rescued i
was brought to the children's advocacy
center in salt lake
where i was told that i needed to speak
with these two uh psychiatrists
and so in my mind i was like well if
they're psychiatrists that means therapy
and uh so they're gonna try to help me
or
fix me but i went in there and
um like my i didn't really want my
parents in there with me
um because i didn't want them to know
what had happened to me um
but i was in there with these two
middle-aged guys men men
that i didn't know and they were both
clearly religious which i mean good for
them for practicing their religion
and then i was left alone in there with
them i had just been taken out of
a situation where i was you know
abused extensively and sexually by
a middle-aged religious man and so then
i was put i felt like i was put right
back into that situation
and they started to ask me questions
about what happened what it was like
but um i mean being who i was i was
still very shy at that time i was still
very
awkward and self-conscious and
um that didn't change just because i had
been kidnapped
and they started saying okay well what
happened and just just as a an example
of
what it went like um like well yeah he
hurt me they'd be like well how did he
hurt you
like well he blessed me and they'd be
like well can you you know what did he
do and i was like okay well
he raped me and i'd be like well you
know do you know what rapist i was like
well he you know forced himself on me
and they'd be like well
can you explain it to us with the right
body parts until
it was this whole like
pathway of getting to finally saying
he forced his penis inside my vagina
multiple times multiple times a day
and um for me that was pretty traumatic
saying that i'm i mean i
like i felt awkward saying the words
penis and vagina anyways
but then saying it
admitting that that's when it happened
to me first of all
but then being alone with these two men
that was pretty that was pretty
traumatic
and i like of course as an adult now
i've realized they were just trying to
do their job everyone was trying to
do the best that they could but honestly
i don't think anyone had ever
dealt with an experience like mine
before i don't think anyone really knew
what a best practice was or what they
should do
and so that was awful i had to go back
two or three days all day being there
with them and
and i hated it and by the time i was
done with it
i just i just remember thinking i never
want to speak to anyone about this ever
again
i don't want to talk to a psychiatrist i
don't want to talk to anyone else
about this i just i just don't want to
talk about it yeah
you appreciate they were trying to do
their job but like someone wasn't
thinking straight that day when they
thought i know what we'll do we'll put
her in well you know it's
just a red flag isn't it it doesn't make
sense was that was that the only time
you
offered it and was that the only time
you had uh psychiatric help
i mean they actually weren't there to
give me help
they were actually so what my parents
were told was that
if they could get like collect my story
from me
they could actually stand proxy for me
in the trial
and so my parents i mean naturally
wanting to protect me thought that it
would be better for me if i didn't have
to go and face my captors again
and that if these two men could stand as
proxy for me
um then that would be the best the best
choice but i did not fully understand
that at the time and since they simply
have the title of psychiatrist
i um i was like no
no no no i don't want to do this again
and i mean my parents they were
incredibly worried about me
and they actually went and they were
seeing psychiatrists they were seeing a
therapist
and they're just like what do we do what
do we do she doesn't want to talk about
it she doesn't want to see
anyone and the therapist was like it's
okay
it's okay just breathe like
let her make this choice on her own
because it might not be today it might
not be tomorrow
but there may come a day when she's
ready to talk about it
and you might be the one she decides to
tell her story to
and you need to make sure you are in a
place where you can listen to it
and you need to make sure that you are
in a place to help her because
both of you are going to be her biggest
therapist more than any
other paid professional could ever be so
you need to make sure that both of you
are in a place where you can help her
and so
they continue to see a therapist and now
as an adult and actually an advocate for
therapy i think therapy is is amazing
and
i i wish i had uh had a better
understanding of it
you know at as a teenager after i was
rescued because i think i just thought
oh you go to someone's office you you
lie on their leather settee and you
and you just talk about the worst
moments of your life over and over and
over until you get it out of your system
yeah i think that was my as the extent
of my
understanding of therapy went and now
um i mean there are like that is not
therapy
okay so you've had it you've had it
since then i would assume
by the way you're advocating for it so i
have learned so much more about it and
as i look back on my life i think that
there are so many different forms of
therapy i mean
i find personally for me the outdoors
are incredibly healing for me and i've
spent a lot of time outside
and i love horses and i think there's
something very therapeutic about being
around horses and i spend a lot of time
around horses
honestly my whole life it's always been
a passion of mine
even from before i was kidnapped i grew
up playing the harp
and i played the harp again after i was
kidnapped and anytime that i
i couldn't express how i felt or what i
was thinking i
i know it sounds cliche but i always
felt music was
um a way i could articulate my feelings
without
actually verbally articulating them
and yeah so i mean i felt like i had a
lot of different forms of therapy
and as an adult like i i have
gone and seen therapists i mean not
necessarily related to
um my kidnapping but i mean
we've talked about it but i mean who
doesn't need a little advice
now and then he doesn't need a little
pat on the back and
it's kind of nice knowing that you can
say your
deepest darkest thoughts and they are
not allowed to share it with anyone else
yeah and going back to the music i mean
everyone needs something that soothes
their soul
so you know it's good to have anything
like that isn't it um
i guess i guess the way i always pick
you up from watching some of your
interviews
i thought um you know we all talk to
ourself and
we all have that in a conversation and i
thought you must be very kind to
yourself
and very good to yourself and uh because
to get through something like that i
mean
uh it it kind of just blew my mind how
together you won what a whole person you
are
clearly the family helped but um
do you think that's part of it the way
you have that in a conversation do you
think you're kind to yourself
um i think that's a huge compliment yes
actually um i do i
i like who i am i'm not perfect
i certainly have my days where i
am angry or i cry or i wish things were
different
i mean don't we all have those days like
i am definitely human
but i also know that
i'm a kind person and if i make mistakes
they're not intentional and if i hurt
someone's feelings
it is never intentional and that
that i usually if i know
that i hurt someone's feelings i will
usually feel really bad about it
for a long long time
but i also know that i don't do these
things intentionally and that we
all no matter how hard we try or how
pure our intentions are
none of us get through life unscathed
none of us get through life with
everyone liking us
and so just accepting that fact and just
trying to continue to do the best that i
can is all i really can do and
know that my heart for whatever mistakes
i've made or
will make or are making
my heart is in the right place and that
i
certainly have never set out to destroy
anyone or hurt anyone
unless you're a predator in which case i
have no sympathy
that's one of the most beautiful things
anyone's ever said honestly i love that
i'm really happy that you're in that
place and
and that you just know yourself so well
like that
um you know coming out of all of that
and
and going into you know now you're
married and you've got kids and all of
that
was it um you know i know you're a
strong person but how did you adjust to
just trying to have that regular
you know dating life and meeting people
and all of that um
i mean i think were all the things that
i
felt like had been taken away from me
when i got
rescued i felt like i'd been given a
second chance at him so
i mean before i was kidnapped i'd never
kissed anyone
i'd never held a boy's hand before i may
not hardly ever even spoken to a boy
um and so these are all things that
all of a sudden going from that to being
told that i was married to this
old man it was quite shocking and i felt
like
all of those things had been taken away
from me so they were
certainly things that i was excited
about um
coming home i mean i was excited to go
on my first date i was excited to have
my first boyfriend
um and um there were definitely probably
some
people that i look back and thinking i
should probably should not have bothered
going out with you
probably was not my best decision i mean
not they're
bad people or anything but just
i mean why why did i say yes like
there's really no reason for me to say
yes to you
um i don't necessarily think
i mean i think some people yeah asked me
out simply so they could say they went
out with elizabeth smart
um some people i think were
um genuine um i mean
i guess we all live and learn and then i
mean for my husband
he he was born and raised in scotland he
didn't know who i was so
yeah it was nice to have someone like me
simply for me and honestly even though
um
doing like a podcast with you is not
something out of like
the ordinary you know i i do podcasts i
do public speaking um i have
honestly i've done some pretty amazing
things in my life that i never would
have dreamed
that i would ever do um it's never
it's never played into my relationship
with my husband um and one thing i
really admire about what you've done
is you've really you know they took nine
months from you
but you haven't let them take any more
than that and that's
uh so special and powerful that you've
managed to do that
um i was reading up and i i heard that
unfortunately
the woman has been released not long ago
is that
is that are you aware of all of that and
how did that make you feel
yeah so she was released she's i think
it was about 18
months ago maybe it's two years ago just
can't even
i don't know i'm gonna blame it on the
pandemic time it's lost all meaning
yeah we're all the same we're inside
every week's the same yeah yeah
but um it was a disappointment yeah it
was
it was a disappointment it felt like
felt like i was being let down um
but i think that being said it helped me
i mean i should be grateful that i got
at least 15 years of of her being locked
away
of justice because there are so many
cases
i mean the vast vast majority of
of you know these kinds of cases their
abusers
don't ever even serve a day in prison
yeah
and so i think that gave me greater
compassion and understanding
for all of those other victims out there
and how terrible it must be for them
you know wondering if they're gonna come
home tonight and is someone gonna crawl
into their bed that they don't want in
their bed
or when they go to the next family
reunion
how are they going to avoid that one
that one relative
and if they speak out who is going to
believe them
and who is going to believe that one
relative i mean i think
it really helped me understand more
where these other victims are coming
from
um and i mean yeah
it was a disappointment i can't this
yeah nothing it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace in my opinion because
she was so complicit in everything that
went on and so
much a part of it that she should never
have seen the light of day in my opinion
but
and the crazy thing after i did a little
bit of reading was that
she's now living near a school and after
everything she did with child it's
it's disgusting how this thing just
happens and we all just sort of go along
with it
um because you know uh government
is just so full of [__] um sorry
but yeah um and and one of the other
things that
um i i read up on was that you know
shockingly you were a victim of sexual
assault later in
your life on an airplane as well
which gives you a whole another
experience because now you are this
strong person who's overcome all of this
horror and you're experiencing something
else
it's just unbelievable what happened
there
it is actually still an active case that
the
fbi are still working on
so they've asked me not to say too much
about it
but i will say that it made me so angry
that something like this could happen
again i mean seriously
like this
uh this is not okay and if it can happen
to me
again i mean how many more people is it
happening to
i mean how many victims are there that
just aren't saying
anything because it is a hassle
it does take forever and is justice ever
really served yeah it's hard to say
i mean my eyes have been opened a lot in
the last few years you know
um through people like yourself speaking
out another victims
but yeah the fact that you've had such
terrific things happen
twice is it just proves it's far too
common
um can we talk a little bit about some
of the positive stuff that you've
managed to do off the back of this
because
i was talking to um your friend sage uh
before we did this
and you guys are you've got some amazing
things going on like
online self defense classes for women
and uh
you know you've been been an activist
for years in fact so let's talk about
some of the positive stuff okay yeah i'd
love to
so yeah so um we
are we have a self-defense class that we
offer and are working on spreading that
and making it more available obviously
as we're still in the middle of a
pandemic it's a bit hard but we're
working on it
and so we've been working to try to get
that online and we hope to launch that
very soon so that anyone can do it
anywhere but
um i mean self-defense i mean you would
know
more than anyone else i mean it's not
just something you can go through once
and be like yeah i'm good i'm done
i mean for that to actually become
instinct it's something you have to
practice every single day so
um for as much as we
promote you know our self-defense system
or any self-defense system for that
matter
we also promote practicing it and
thinking about it and staying up to date
on it because otherwise
it's not going to be there when you need
it and
and that being said i also just want to
say that even if you do practice it
every day
you never know how you're going to
respond i mean my
my head my director for this whole
self-defense program you know she is
a world champion for her weight class in
jiu jitsu
and um she you know she'll she'll be the
first one to say
i practice this every day i could still
get raped tomorrow
this might not come to my mind when i
need it
because it's something you don't expect
to happen to you
you think you're so prepared you don't
expect
people in polite modern day civilized
what we think is humanity
[Music]
to act this way and so even with all
this training it is still
possible to happen but you know it helps
build your confidence it helps show you
what you
are capable of how strong you really are
and even if you can just build your
confidence up just a little bit more
whether it's you know through
self-defense or even just working out
so much the better because predators
look for vulnerability
they look for opportunity and so if you
have a little extra confidence in your
step that might make you
you know take you down just a notch on
that vulnerability scale just a little
bit
and so you you you don't know so um
with our self-defense sorry speaking
from experience as well because i'm a
huge martial arts fan
and i study i do boxing as well like
someone who a man who is untrained and
is
an opportunist like that against a woman
who is trained
you know that isn't a full-grown
conclusion the way it would be
ordinarily if she wasn't trained like
she's gonna
she's gonna show him some [__] and he
might regret that whole and fingers
crossed
i mean women should not need this
obviously but it's fantastic that you
are doing that absolutely and i
i mean i don't want this to happen to
anyone
but i hope if any man does try to take
advantage of a woman who has been
through training
i hope she destroys him amen um
but yeah you've been you've been a great
public speaker as well in america like
um
i i heard your name is google like a
hundred thousand times a month because
you're still so such a strong voice
for victims and um you've done a lot of
that haven't you
um i have i have been i have been
very active i have done speaking and
presentations and in all 50 states um i
go up to canada
i would say semi-regularly except
nothing's regular right now
um i heard you were trying to help with
the law change in regards to
the native american situation so
so we are actually launching our find
them all campaign
tomorrow okay great um because
native americans they and and indigenous
people
they make up anywhere from point eight
percent to two percent of our total
population
in america and yet the statistics
they're they are so skewed they make up
over 40 of our human trafficking victims
here in america
and you think how can you know two
percent or less of the total population
almost make up half of our human
trafficking victims in america that
seems so off
and i mean if you're if you
are a woman and you're native american
or indigenous
like four out of five women are sexually
assaulted in their lifetime
it almost comes to the point of not a
question of
if it happens but when it happens
and it is it's just so
unfair um on every level
i mean kind of going off of what we were
talking a little bit about earlier my
case
received so much attention
i mean people to this day still approach
me in the grocery store
um they still tell me they still say
things to me like
you know there are a couple times in my
life where i remember exactly where i
was
the first one was when jfk was shot and
the second one
was when you were found i remember
exactly where i was i remember exactly
what i was doing
i mean i've had that comment made to me
actually many many times and
um that even right there just shows me
how much attention my case got and to
think
that there are so many women and girls
who are native and indigenous
missing right now and yet
i can think of maybe one no can't even
think of one
one of their names i haven't seen any of
them on the news
i mean it's just it's unfair and it
needs to change
and so we need to raise awareness um we
are hoping to
um so we are our campaign is
uh a seven day seven workout challenge
to raise funds so that we can get these
specialized
scent kits distributed across
reservations so that we can get these if
i go missing files
that actually another podcast crime
junkies have
put together that is honestly so
impressive um get these files
distributed out
across reservations and then be able to
have we have this
bloodhound who um has been trained
not just to track disturbance in the
ground but to actually
follow scent the way that it was
described to me is that
people each one of us we're each like
our own
individual pig pen um like from the
character
from charlie brown we all walk around
with like a dust
a dust cloud around of us of scent of
cells
of um whatever else we put off
and so these dogs they are able to track
that
dust cloud essentially that follows us
everywhere
we go and so that's what we want to be
able to do because one of the other big
um problems is that when these native
and indigenous women go missing
they are lucky if they get a case number
at all
um they it often can take up to two
weeks
to get a case number just a case number
and
unfortunately the first 48 hours are
honestly the most crucial crucial if
you're not found within the first 48
hours
there's a pretty good chance you won't
be found at all so if you think it's
taking
two weeks just to get a case number your
chances of being found are not good at
all so we want to try to change that we
want to try to help
bridge that gap have booths on the
ground looking for these
women and girls within the first 24
hours
having dogs out there trying to send
them trying to find them
um and and hopefully i mean it is hard
and i i mean i'm not a police officer
i'm not an fbi
officer um but each one of these
reservations
is essentially its own sovereign nation
within america
and so they have their tribal police
officers
who have jurisdiction over the
reservation
but not off of the reservation and then
we have the police officers who are not
on the reservation who have jurisdiction
you know off of the reservation but not
on the reservation
and so it gets it gets very confusing
very difficult and very confusing
because
you know whose job is it yeah well i
mean congratulations on getting involved
in
raising money and doing you know your
best to help the situation and i really
hope it makes a difference i'm sure it
will
i guess i've only got one more question
left because i've taken a lot of your
time
so i do appreciate that my final
question
is how would you like to be remembered
how do i want to be remembered
a good person a kind person
someone who did their best
someone who tried to make a difference
that's good enough well you
you're definitely that there's no doubt
about it um i just want to say a big
thanks again honestly you're
absolute inspiration and
yeah i'm just really grateful for the
time i've never i've never done a story
like this on my podcast it's very new i
was a bit nervous if i'm honest and
you're absolutely lovely
and um yeah just keep doing everything
you're doing and if you ever need
anything
uh we've got some followers on social
media so like
you know maybe i could send some um
traction to anything that you're trying
to work on to help you out
um but yeah what is your website for
anyone who wants to get involved with
the self-defense stuff so it's elizabeth
smart foundation
and then i mean of course we're on
facebook
wrong instagram look up elizabeth i mean
you look up elizabeth smart and i'll
come up
and of course my foundation is is right
there with me
or you can just simply look up elizabeth
smart foundation it's right there as
well
well i hope everyone enjoyed the story
i'm pretty sure it was um
an emotional ride but um you know you're
doing so great um don't forget to hit
the like button guys
hit the subscribe button thanks for
watching and we'll see you later
thank you